This episode of 100 Objects is brought to you by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the AI for minds that don't stop at good enough. It's the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and thinks with you. Whether you're debugging code at midnight or strategizing your next business move, Claude extends your thinking to tackle the problems that matter. Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code.
本期《100件物品》由 Claude 的幕后团队 Anthropic 赞助播出。Claude 是专为精益求精的头脑打造的 AI。它是真正理解你整个工作流程并与你并肩思考的协作者。无论你是在半夜调试代码，还是为下一步商业决策运筹帷幄，Claude 都能拓展你的思维，帮你攻克关键难题。通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用。定制计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至是原型，全程无需编写一行代码。
For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at claw.a.i. That's clod.a.i. The year is 1886. The Civil War is still within living memory. Veterans in their 40s and 50s are prominent figures in public life. And President Chester A. Arthur, himself a veteran, has been out of office for less than two years. And don't worry, it's okay if you forgot. that Chester A. Arthur was ever a president to begin with.
要解决值得攻克的问题，请访问 claw.a.i 开始使用 Claude。即 c-l-o-d 点 a 点 i。时间是 1886 年。内战仍在人们的记忆中犹存。四五十岁的退伍军人在公众生活中举足轻重。而切斯特·A·亚瑟总统本人也是一名退伍军人，他卸任还不到两年。别担心，如果你忘了切斯特·A·亚瑟曾经当过总统，也没关系。
He's someone who has almost totally disappeared from the public memory and imagination for most people. That's Elliot Kalen, Emmy-winning TV writer, author, comedian, and podcaster. And he's obsessed with President Chester A. Arthur. He was involved in what you could call shenanigans, or what you could also call political corruption. He was very much a figure of his time, and that meant he was involved with a lot of shady dealings, the types of dealings that involve buying votes,
对大多数人来说，他是一个几乎完全从公众记忆和想象中消失的人。说话的是埃利奥特·卡伦，艾美奖得主、电视编剧、作家、喜剧演员兼播客主持人。他迷恋上了切斯特·A·亚瑟总统。他卷入了你可以称之为胡闹的事情，或者你也可以称之为政治腐败的事情。他非常具有那个时代的特征，这意味着他卷入了许多见不得光的交易，那种涉及买选票的交易，
bribery, graft, that kind of corruption. But these are not the things that you want people of the future or even necessarily your descendants knowing about it. And this concern is front of mind because Chester Arthur is currently dying of kidney disease. And on his deathbed, After years of public service and years of semi-public shenanigans, he's going to try to erase all the evidence.
行贿、贪污，诸如此类的腐败。但这些并不是你想让未来的人甚至你的后代知道的事情。这种担忧迫在眉睫，因为切斯特·亚瑟当时正患肾病，生命垂危。在他临终前，在经历了多年的公共服务和半公开的胡闹之后，他试图抹去所有的证据。
And so he directs his son to burn his personal and professional papers. His barrels worth of papers. And he says, burn all of them. Three garbage barrels, each around four feet high, stuffed with every paper from Chester Arthur's life and set on fire. Well, not every paper. A few survived the purge. Among those were 23 letters that were initialed J.I.S.
于是他指示他的儿子烧毁他的个人和职业文件。整整好几桶的文件。他说，把它们全烧了。三个垃圾桶，每个大约四分之高，塞满了切斯特·亚瑟生前的每一份文件，然后付之一炬。好吧，也不是每一份文件。有几份在清洗中幸存了下来。其中包括 23 封首字母为 J.I.S. 的信件。
In which we now know are from a woman named Julius Hand, a woman that Chester Arthur had never met before she started writing to him, that nobody really knew. She was not a public figure. She was just a regular person. Just a bundle of letters from an unknown woman. No name anyone recognized. These are the letters remaining from his legacy. And they are the reason Elliot is so obsessed with Chester Arthur.
我们现在知道，这些信件来自一位名叫朱莉娅·桑的女性。在朱莉娅开始给他写信之前，切斯特·亚瑟从未见过她，也没有人真正认识她。她不是公众人物。她只是一个普通人。只是一捆来自不知名女性的信件。没有谁认得的名字。这些是他的遗产中仅存的信件。而它们正是埃利奥特如此迷恋切斯特·亚瑟的原因。
The way the story is often told, and I'm always wondering if this is a real thing or if it's just a touch of romanticizing history, that the letters were wrapped together in a ribbon. And the papers that did survive, Arthur's family turned them over to the Library of Congress. And that it wasn't until decades later that people really noticed these papers existed and bothered to go through them, which is too bad because Julia Sand lived into the 1930s. There were many years where someone could have, if they had known of the existence of these papers, tracked her down and asked her about what happened. Elliot wishes we knew more about Julia Sand, who she was outside these letters, what made her audacious enough to write to a president when she was a nobody. She was just an unmarried woman living in New York City, largely homebound with no political ties, no platform, and no reason to think the president would listen to her. But what we do know is that her letters were key to one of the most amazing transformations in American history, a politician who owed so much. to a corrupt system would become the one to dismantle it. These letters from Julia Sand seemed to have incited a major change of heart in Chester Arthur that turned him from the symbol of all that was corrupt and slimy in American politics to a champion of civil service reform, the most exciting type of reform someone could possibly be
这个故事通常的讲述方式是——我一直在纳闷这到底是真事，还是只给历史增添了一抹浪漫色彩——那些信件是用一根丝带捆在一起的。而那些幸存下来的文件，亚瑟的家人将其交给了国会图书馆。直到几十年后，人们才真正注意到这些文件的存在，并费心去翻阅它们，这太糟糕了，因为朱莉娅·桑活到了 20 世纪 30 年代。在那之后的许多年里，如果有人知道这些文件的存在，本可以找到她，并向她询问当年发生了什么。埃利奥特真希望我们能对朱莉娅·桑了解更多：她在这些信件之外是一个什么样的人，是什么让她有这么大的胆量，在自己寂寂无名时敢于给总统写信。她只是一个住在纽约市的未婚女性，大门不出二门不迈，没有政治人脉，没有发声平台，也没有任何理由认为总统会听她说话。但我们确实知道，她的信件是美国历史上最惊人的变革之一的关键：一个从腐败体制中获得如此之多的政客，竟然会成为拆除该体制的人。朱莉娅·桑的这些信件似乎激起了切斯特·亚瑟思想上的重大转变，使他从美国政治中所有腐败和卑劣事物的象征，变成了公务员制度改革的捍卫者——这可以说是所有人最梦寐以求的改革。虽然不是最刺激的，但却是最重要的改革举措之一。公务员制度改革，意味着雇用那些真正有资格胜任政府工作的人。所以这确实是一个关键的转折点，介于一个拥有非专业政府（你根本指望不上它能做好任何事）的美国，与当今政府之间——在当今政府中，甚至那些不喜欢它的人也习以为常，认为它做了很多事并取得了很大成就。亚瑟开创的这种基于专业功绩的官僚体制，让美国得以实现我们在 20 世纪取得的所有成就。我们登上了月球。我们赢得了战争。我们通过了民权立法。如果没有胜任的政府，
involved in. It's not the most exciting, but one of the most important pieces of reform. Civil service reform, meaning hiring people to work in the government who are actually qualified to do their jobs. So it really is this hinge point between a United States that has a non-professional government that you cannot count on to do pretty much anything, to the government of today where even the people who don't like it take it for granted, that it does a lot of stuff and accomplishes a lot of things. What Arthur started, that professional merit-based bureaucracy, it allowed America to accomplish everything we accomplished in the 20th century. We landed on the moon. We won wars. We passed civil rights legislation. None of that happens without competent government
这一切都不会发生。
workers. And that all can be traced back to 23 letters from Julia Isabella Sand. She seems to have inspired him to help lay the groundwork for the modern government that we have today and that we take for granted today. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the sand letters to President Chester Allen Arthur. The story of how a woman no one had ever heard of helped transform a president, if you remember, and in the process, created the American government as we know it. So let's start back in classic e-shaped narrative structure to the beginning of Chester Arthur's life.
而这一切都可以追溯到朱莉娅·伊莎贝拉·桑写下的 23 封信。她似乎启发了他，为我们今天拥有的、并且习以为常的现代政府奠定了基础。来自《99%无形》与 BBC 工作室，这里是“100件物品中的美国历史”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天的主题是写给切斯特·艾伦·亚瑟总统的桑氏信件。这个故事讲述了一个默默无闻的女性如何帮助改变了一位总统——如果你还记得他的话——并在过程中塑造了我们今天所知的美国政府。那么，让我们回到经典的 E 形叙事结构，从切斯特·亚瑟一生的起点开始讲起。
Like, what do we know about this guy? He was born in Vermont. His father was an abolitionist preacher, so they would get kicked out of towns. because he would get a job as a preacher and then start preaching abolition and then they'd have to move. People didn't like that. And this is all in, and obviously if he's an abolitionist preacher, this is all pre-Civil War. This is in the first half of the 19th century. So before Chester Arthur will become a shady politician, he starts out as an idealist like his abolitionist father.
比如说，我们对这家伙了解多少？他出生在佛蒙特州。他的父亲是一位废奴主义传教士，所以他们经常被赶出小镇，因为他父亲找到一份传教士的工作后就开始宣扬废奴主义，然后他们就得搬家。人们不喜欢这样。这一切都发生在——显然，如果他是个废奴主义传教士，这一切都发生在内战之前。这是在 19 世纪上半叶。所以在切斯特·亚瑟成为一个藏污纳垢的政客之前，他一开始和他的废奴主义父亲一样是个理想主义者。
He's a young lawyer in New York when he takes on the case of a black woman who was forced off a street car because of her race. And he fought her case and won. And from that point on, New York streetcars were not segregated by race anymore. And so there's the sense that he really was affected in some way by his father's beliefs in that he took on this case and fought it in one. But it's during the Civil War that Arthur starts to reveal his true gift. He could get things done that basically no one else could. He was a quartermaster based in New York. He was not fighting on the battlefield.
他在纽约当年轻律师时，曾接手过一个黑人女性的案件，她因为种族原因被赶出了一辆街车。他为她的案子进行了抗辩并赢得了诉讼。从那时起，纽约的街车不再按种族隔离。所以人们有一种感觉，他确实在某种程度上受到了他父亲信仰的影响，因为他接了这个案子并打赢了。但正是在内战期间，亚瑟开始展现出他真正的天赋。他能把基本上没有人能搞定的事情办成。他曾是驻扎在纽约的军需官。他没有在前线战斗。
He was in charge of moving stuff from one place to another. He is doing the unglamorous work of, oh, people need something. I'm going to go get them that thing and make sure they have it. And one of the stories about that is the troops that were coming through New York and going out, they needed socks. They really needed socks. And this is the kind of thing that when you're fighting a war, you need socks. It's not like you have to have things on your feet to keep your feet clean and dry and healthy. With the due civil warian actments, no one is the guy who collects the socks and gives them to people.
他负责把物资从一个地方运到另一个地方。他做的是那些毫无光彩的工作，比如：哦，人们需要某种东西。我要去把那个东西弄来，确保他们拥有它。关于这一点，其中一个故事是，路过纽约并即将出征的部队需要袜子。他们非常需要袜子。而这就是那种你在打仗时必不可少的东西。这可不是那种你非得穿在脚上保持脚部清洁、干燥和健康的东西。在内战法案通过后，没有人是那个专门收集袜子并分发给人们的人。
But they needed socks. And the person who had been hired to do this, he's dragging his feet, no, intended on getting these socks made. And Arthur is like, what is going on? We need socks for these people. I'm going to find this guy. I have to get him. And they go, oh, it's Sunday. So he's not working today. He goes, what church does he go to? Then Arthur sends his aid to that church. And basically goes up to his pew and drags him out in the middle of the church service. It's like, we need these socks. Like you need to make them. The troops need socks. And they got made. Like many things with Chester Arthur, it's not overtly exciting. But it is.
但他们确实需要袜子。而那个被雇用做这件事的人却在拖延，完全没有把这些袜子赶制出来。亚瑟就觉得：这到底是怎么回事？这些人需要袜子。我要找到这家伙。我必须找到他。然后别人说，哦，今天是星期天。所以他今天不上班。亚瑟问：他去哪个教堂？然后亚瑟派他的助手去了那个教堂。直接走到他的长椅旁，在礼拜进行到一半时把他强行拉了出去。那架势就像是：我们需要这些袜子。你需要把它们做出来。部队需要袜子。于是袜子做出来了。就像切斯特·亚瑟做的许多事情一样，它表面上看起来并不怎么激动人心。但它在实际和管理层面上却意义重大。
important in its practical and managerial effects. But Arthur's gift for getting things done is about to be redirected away from the public good. Because quickly, Arthur catches the attention of arguably the most powerful and corrupt political boss in New York City. Roscoe Conkling. Roscoe Conkling is one of the great political characters of American history. And he's another one where it's too bad people don't remember him because he is so flamboyantly sinister. I guess you can put it in some ways. Or so, he is so openly power-hungry and aggressive.
然而，亚瑟把事情办妥的天赋即将被转移到远离公共利益的方向。因为很快，亚瑟就引起了纽约市可以说是最具权势、最腐败的政治老板的注意。罗斯科·康克林。罗斯科·康克林是美国历史上伟大的政治人物之一。他也是那种人们不记得他实在太可惜的人，因为他实在是——怎么说呢——张扬而阴险。或者说，他是如此公开地渴望权力和具有侵略性。
He was an amateur boxer, and he was always challenging people to fights, basically. But in his position, he was very powerful in the New York spoils system. And we're going to be talking about the spoil system quite a bit in this episode. So buckle up. It's going to be exciting and thrilling. The spoil system refers to how government jobs were handed out at the time. There's an old saying, to the victors go the spoils. And that's the entire logic of the spoil system.
他曾是个业余拳击手，总是动不动就挑战别人打架。但在他的位置上，他在纽约的分赃体制中非常有权势。我们在本集中会经常讨论分赃体制。所以系好安全带吧。这将会是一场惊险刺激的旅程。分赃体制指的是当时的政府职位是如何分配的。有一句老话：胜者为王，分赃同享。这就是分赃体制的全部逻辑。
If you win an election, you get to reward your supporters with government jobs. Maybe you make them a postmaster. Maybe they work for the Treasury Department. Maybe they run a customs house. It doesn't matter if they've never done that job before. What matters is they helped you win. And this is a period when every time the federal government changes hands from one president to another, pretty much everybody loses their job and new people get hired.
如果你赢得了一场选举，你就可以用政府职位来奖赏你的支持者。也许你让他们当邮政局长。也许他们在财政部工作。也许他们管理海关。他们以前从未做过那份工作也无所谓。重要的是他们帮助你赢得了选举。这是一个每当联邦政府在不同总统之间易手时，几乎所有人都会失去工作并招募新人的时期。
If a state changes its governor, now the people who support the party during that, they can go up and say like, I was canvassing for you all over the fourth ward. Like, you need to give me a job. All right, all right, I will. This job just opened up because I fired the guy who did it. They're like, you can work in this insane asylum. Do you have any experience with psychiatry? No.
如果一个州的州长换了人，那么在此期间支持该党的人就可以走上前去说：我在第四选区到处为你拉选票。你需要给我一份工作。好吧，好吧，我会的。这份工作刚刚空出来，因为我把原来干这活的人给解雇了。他们就像是：你可以去这家精神病院工作。你有精神病学方面的经验吗？没有。
Okay, well, the job is yours. That's fine. At this time, Roscoe Conkling is huge in the spoil system in New York. He has influence over who got jobs and where they'd be placed. Conkling takes a liking to Chester Arthur and makes sure Arthur lands one of the cushiest government jobs in all of the country, the collector of the Port of New York. It's really hard now in the world we live in to really grasp how important the customs house at the Port of New York was in the late 19th century. This is a time when there is no income tax. There's very few taxes of any kind.
好吧，那这工作归你了。没问题。在这个时期，罗斯科·康克林在纽约的分赃体制中举足轻重。他对谁能获得工作以及被分配到哪里有着巨大的影响力。康克林看中了切斯特·亚瑟，并确保亚瑟获得了全国最肥缺的政府职位之一——纽约港海关收税官。在我们生活的这个世界里，现在很难真正理解 19 世纪末纽约港海关的重要性。那是一个没有所得税的时代。几乎没有任何形式的税收。
I don't believe there are any sales taxes. And so as a result, the main source for government money is customs duties on the goods coming into the port of New York, which at the time is the biggest port in the country. About two-thirds of all the government's revenue came from import taxes through the port of New York alone, the port that Chester Arthur was now in charge of. If you're in control of the port of New York, if you're in the job of collector, then you have the ability to not just hire hundreds of people because there's something like 12,300 people who work at that port. but you also have the ability to control and direct so much money. It's at the port and under the tutelage of Roscoe Conkling that Arthur learns how the game is played. Fines, kickbacks, goods that disappeared from warehouses and mysteriously found their way into the hands of his friends. He made so much money, in fact, that for a while his income was double that of the president of the United States.
我不认为当时有什么销售税。因此，政府资金的主要来源是进入当时全国最大港口——纽约港的货物的关税。当时政府大约三分之二的收入仅来自通过纽约港的进口税，而这个港口正是切斯特·亚瑟现在掌管的港口。如果你控制了纽约港，如果你担任收税官这个职务，那么你不仅有能力雇用数百人——因为大约有 12,300 人在那个港口工作——而且你还有能力控制和支配巨额资金。正是在这个港口，在罗斯科·康克林的悉心指导下，亚瑟学会了这场游戏的玩法。罚款、回扣、从仓库中消失并神秘地落入他朋友手中的货物。事实上，他赚了如此多的钱，以至于有一段时间他的收入是美国总统的两倍。
And he's a guy who likes fancy clothes. He likes to own fancy things. He was famous at the time for owning somewhere between 70 and 80 pairs of pants, which is a lot of pants even now. Most people, I think, did not own 70 to 80 items of clothing. They might not have owned 70 to 80 possessions. And that's how many pants he had. And late 19th century eyes, his clothes would have been very fashionable for a dignified grown man. Arthur didn't create the spoil system, but he was its most respectable face, the impeccably dressed gentleman boss who makes corruption look fashionable.
他是个喜欢奇装异服的人。他喜欢拥有昂贵的东西。他当时以拥有 70 到 80 条裤子而闻名，即使在现在这也是很多条裤子。我想大多数人当时连 70 到 80 件衣服都没有。他们可能连 70 到 80 件财产都没有。而这就是他拥有的裤子数量。在 19 世纪末的人看来，他的衣服对于一个尊严的成年男性来说会非常时髦。亚瑟并没有创造分赃体制，但他却是它最体面的门面，那个衣着无可挑剔的绅士老板，让腐败看起来很时髦。
But regular Americans were getting increasingly frustrated with the system. After the Civil War, people were encountering the federal government in an entirely new way. Soldiers and widows needed their pensions filled, and mail started coming to people's doors. Suddenly, it was more obvious when government workers weren't doing their jobs. People now expect the government to have a little thing called competence, which they weren't really expecting or caring about before. And this means that the level of spoils corruption is really much more visible to people than it was more. And it's much more on the top of their minds. In fact, there's a huge fight brewing in the Republican Party over this.
但普通的美国人对这个体制越来越感到沮丧。内战之后，人们以一种全新方式接触联邦政府。士兵和寡妇需要他们的抚恤金得到处理，邮件开始送到人们的家门口。突然之间，当政府工作人员没有做好他们的工作时，这一点就变得更加明显了。人们现在期望政府具备一点名为“能力”的东西，而在此之前，他们并没有真正期望或关心过这一点。这意味着分赃体制带来的腐败比以前更加显眼。而且这也更加占据他们的心头。事实上，共和党内部正围绕这一点酝酿着一场巨大的斗争。
Half of the party, called the stalwarts, people like Arthur and Conkling, want to keep things as they were. But the other half, the reformers, want to change the system. And this fight becomes a huge problem when trying to figure out who should run for president in the election of 1880. And so there is this big split between the side that wants to keep the system going the way it is, that loves it, that profits from it, that understands it, and the side that wants to reform it and change the way that the government does things. And that split in the Republican Party plays out in real time on the convention floor in 1880. They vote once, they vote again and again dozens of times, but the party can't agree on a presidential nominee. Then a congressman from Ohio named James Garfield gives a speech. that electrifies the delegates.
党内的一半人被称为“坚守派”（Stalwarts），像亚瑟和康克林这样的人，希望维持现状。但另一半人，即改革派，想要改变体制。而当试图确定谁应该在 1880 年大选中竞选总统时，这场斗争成了一个巨大的问题。因此，党内存在巨大分裂：一方希望维持现状、热爱现状、从中获利并理解现状；另一方则希望改革并改变政府做事的方式。共和党内的这种分裂在 1880 年的代表大会会场上实时上演。他们投了一轮又一轮，几十轮下来，但党内无法就总统候选人达成一致。接着，来自俄亥俄州的国会议员詹姆斯·加菲尔德发表了一场演讲，
Suddenly, he's getting votes, and he wins the nomination in a landslide. Garfield is a family man, preacher, lawyer, a former Civil War general, guided by his principles that government should work based on merit, not political favors. So he's a reformer, but the Republican Party knows that if they're actually going to win the presidency, they need to make the vice president someone from the spoil system faction to balance the ticket and draw the stalwart vote. And so they ask Arthur to be vice president. The feeling was very much, we're going to heal the party, we're going to have a united front.
让代表们为之振奋。转瞬间，他赢得了选票，并以压倒性优势赢得提名。加菲尔德是一个顾家的男人、传教士、律师、前内战将军，他坚信政府应该基于才能而非政治恩惠来运作。所以他是个改革派，但共和党人知道，如果他们真的想赢得总统宝座，他们需要让副总统由分赃派系的人担任，以平衡竞选阵营并争取坚守派的选票。于是他们邀请亚瑟担任副总统。当时的感觉非常强烈：我们要修复党派，我们要建立一个统一战线。
It'll be Garfield, the reformer, with Arthur the old hand stalwart as his vice president. But the vice president doesn't do anything. So it'll be fine. It'll be fantastic. This will work perfectly. And Arthur, for his part, is so excited about the idea of being vice president. Conkling comes to him, and he has this quote that I love so much. Arthur says they've asked me to be vice president
这将是改革派加菲尔德，搭配老练的坚守派亚瑟作为他的副总统。但副总统什么也不用做。所以没关系。这太棒了。这会完美运作。而亚瑟本人，对于当副总统这个想法感到非常兴奋。康克林来找他，他说了一句我非常喜欢的话。亚瑟说他们邀请我当副总统，
and he goes, you drop that like it was a horseshoe hot from the forge. Like he's so mad about it because he hates Garfield. And Arthur is like, I never dreamed of being vice president. I have to take it. And in his understanding of it, Arthur's understanding, this will be the ultimate, wonderful no-show job where all he has to do is be likable, hang around. He probably still wants some, wants to keep his hand into the system,
然后康克林说：你得像扔一块刚从炉子里拿出来的热马蹄铁一样把它扔掉！他对此非常生气，因为他讨厌加菲尔德。而亚瑟则觉得：我从未梦想过能当副总统。我必须接受它。按照他的理解，亚瑟的理解是，这将是终极的美妙的“挂名闲差”，他所需要做的就是讨人喜欢、闲逛。他可能仍然想插手体制，
in the spoil system, because that's how he maintains his role. relationships with a lot of the people in his life. And so I think there was probably a sense of a step back, but come on, you're not going to take the vice presidency. You got it. You got to do it. But was there any indication that Arthur wanted the presidency at all? No. In fact, the exact opposite indication was very clear he did not want the presidency. There was, there I think is maybe no one in the history of the United States who has ever been one heartbeat away from the presidency who wished more that he was millions of heartbeats away from the presidency. He really doesn't want it. Most men in the back of their minds are like,
插手分赃体制，因为那是他维持与生活中许多人关系的方式。所以我想当时可能有一种退让的感觉，但拜托，你总不能不接受副总统职位吧。你必须接受。你必须这么做。但有没有任何迹象表明亚瑟根本想要总统职位？没有。事实上，完全相反的迹象非常明显：他根本不想要总统职位。在美国历史上，可能没有哪个人距离总统宝座只有一步之遥，却比他更希望自己距离总统宝座有数百万步之遥。他真的不想要。大多数人在心底里都会想：
yeah, if I was president, I'd do a pretty good job. I think I could do this. And I think in Arthur's case, he's one of the rare men who was like, I would not be good at this. I do not want this. It is too difficult and it's too much responsibility. So he is just, the idea of being president, I think, terrifies him. Well, what Arthur doesn't know yet is that the thing that terrifies him the most is about to come true. In just a few months, the spoil system he's been running and benefiting from will kill a president, and Arthur will finally see what he's been a part of. What is the story of the Garfield shooting? So this is one of the stranger assassinations.
对啊，如果我是总统，我会干得挺不错。我想我能行。但在亚瑟的例子中，他是极少数这样想的人之一：我不适合干这个。我不想当总统。这太难了，责任太重大了。所以他只是——当总统的想法，我想，把他吓坏了。好吧，亚瑟还不知道的是，最让他感到恐惧的事情即将成真。仅仅几个月后，他一直在运营并从中受益的分赃体制将杀死一位总统，而亚瑟也将终于看清他自己一直是其中一部分的现实。加菲尔德遭枪击的经过是怎样的？所以这是最奇怪的暗杀事件之一。
It's terrible that I can categorize presidential assassinations. This is one of the stranger ones because the person who committed it is one of the stranger assassins. And also how it happens would have been so easily avoidable. So it's July 2nd, 1881, James Garfield. is the president, and he's about to take the train out of town. Because it's summer in D.C. and it's disgusting to be in summer in D.C. Everyone's leaving town. I don't think he has any bodyguards.
我能把总统暗杀事件分类，这本身就很糟糕。这是其中较诡异的一起，因为行凶者是一个相当怪异的刺客。而且事情发生的方式本可以非常轻易地避免。那是 1881 年 7 月 2 日，詹姆斯·加菲尔德是总统，他正准备坐火车离开华盛顿。因为华盛顿的夏天实在是太难受了。每个人都在离开小镇。我想他当时没有任何保镖。
So he's just walking to the train. And literally, someone just steps out with a gun and shoots him in the back and then goes, now Chester Arthur is president. Like, you know, America is saved, something like that and gets arrested. So the man who shot President Garfield did so because he wanted Chester Arthur, the VP, to replace him. And after he fired the gun, he said, So out loud, right there at the scene.
所以他只是步行走向火车站。然后字面意义上，某个人突然掏出一支枪朝他后背开了一枪，然后说：现在切斯特·亚瑟是总统了。就像是——你知道的，美国得救了之类的话——然后就被捕了。所以枪击加菲尔德总统的那个人之所以这么做，是因为他想让副总统切斯特·亚瑟取代他。在开枪之后，他就在现场大声说出了这样的话。
What's interesting about this assassination is that it has to do with this spoil system and the stalwarts and the reformers. Like, it really plays into the ideological schism that is happening. Yes, in a very real way, you could say that President Garfield was killed by the spoil system. In a more real way, you could say he was killed by an insane man who was obsessed with the spoil system. But he was, because he was shot in the back by Charles Gutot, who was often described in history books, as a disappointed office seeker, which is technically true. But he was also a mentally disturbed office seeker. And this was a time when it was a huge part of the president's job to just hand out jobs to people, that you could just walk into the White House.
这次暗杀有趣的地方在于，它与分赃体制、坚守派以及改革派有关。它确实反映了当时正在发生的思想分裂。是的，从非常实际的意义上说，你可以说是分赃体制杀死了加菲尔德总统。从更真实的意义上说，你可以说是一个痴迷于分赃体制的精神失常的人杀死了他。但事实确实如此，因为他是被查尔斯·吉托从背后开枪击中的。查尔斯·吉托在历史书中通常被描述为“一个失望的求职者”，这在技术上是正确的。但他也是一个精神失常的求职者。当时，总统工作很大的一部分就是给人们分发官职，你可以直接走进白宫。
You'd wait outside the president's office until it was your turn to see him. The president would say, what do you want? I ran this effort for you for your election in Moose Jaw. I want to be the post clerk of Moose Jaw. Okay, great, you're the postal clerk of Moose Jaw. What Elliot is describing is something that tormented presidents. Lincoln himself, with everything else he was dealing with during the Civil War, was exhausted by the endless stream of office seekers showing up to the White House, demanding a job.
你会在总统办公室外面等待，直到轮到你面见他。总统会问：你想要什么？我为你竞选莫斯乔市长时出了力。我想当莫斯乔的邮政文员。好吧，太棒了，你就是莫斯乔的邮政文员了。埃利奥特所描述的正是那些折磨着历任总统的事情。林肯自己在内战期间还要应付所有其他事情，却也因源源不断来到白宫要求安排工作的求职者而精疲力竭。
It was unsustainable. And most of the day was that meeting over and over again. A woman coming in, my husband needs a job. He supported you. Okay, I'll find a job for him. Goutot was one of those people, but his sights were unrealistically high. And there's stories about him basically like just jumping out of nowhere. Like if Garfield is walking around the White House, Guto jumping out of the bushes and saying, hey, it's me, your friend, Charles Guto, I supported you in the election.
这根本无法持续。大部分时间都在一遍又一遍地进行这种会面。一个女人走进来：我丈夫需要一份工作。他支持过你。好吧，我会为他找份工作的。吉托就是那些人之一，但他的目标高得不切实际。有一些关于他的故事，说他基本上就像是从虚空中突然跳出来一样。如果加菲尔德在白宫周围散步，吉托就会从灌木丛中跳出来说：嘿，是我，你的朋友查尔斯·吉托，我在选举中支持过你。
You should make me ambassador to Vienna. You should make me ambassador to France. Guto is a, he's like the textbook example of someone who is a drifter who cannot figure out a way to make a real life in the world and has this drive to prestige to be part of important events. He believes himself to be a historically important figure at a level that he is not. And with each no, Guto's rage with President Garfield grows. He becomes more and more unhinged until he's sure that the only way to get what he wants is through violence. Let's look at it from Garfield's point of view. This guy keeps jumping out at you and telling you that he should be the ambassador to Vienna.
你应该让我去当驻维也纳大使。你应该让我去当驻法国大使。吉托是一个标准的流浪汉典型，他无法在世界上找到真正谋生的方法，却有着对威望的强烈渴望，想要参与重要事件。他认为自己是一个具有历史重要性的人物，达到了他实际并未达到的高度。伴随着一声声拒绝，吉托对加菲尔德总统的愤怒与日俱增。他变得越来越精神错乱，直到他确信获得自己想要的东西的唯一途径就是暴力。让我们从加菲尔德的角度来看待这件事。这个人不断地跳出来告诉你他应该成为驻维也纳大使。
You don't give him that job. You know, and so Guto becomes convinced. Garfield is the problem, and if Arthur is president, then I will get the job I want. And so he shoots Garfield in the back and is immediately captured, thrown in jail. And even up to, I think, the day of his execution, he is sitting in his jail cell saying, any minute now, Chesteroy Arthur is going to show up at the head of the military and break me out of jail. And he's going to appoint me ambassador, and everything's going to work out fine. Guto was delusional to the end.
你没有给他那份工作。你知道的，于是吉托确信：加菲尔德是问题所在，如果亚瑟当了总统，我就会得到我想要的工作。于是他朝加菲尔德的背部开枪，随后立即被捕并投进监狱。甚至直到他被处决的那天，他仍然坐在监狱的牢房里说：任何一分钟，切斯特·亚瑟都会率领军队出现在这里，把我从监狱里救出来。他会任命我为大使，一切都会顺利解决的。吉托至死都处于妄想之中。
But what he'd actually done shot a president because he felt cheated, by the spoil system was too perfect a symbol. It's almost like Garfield's assassination is a living political cartoon, that Garfield could be labeled reformer, and he's walking through the train station in D.C. And a man labeled spoil system or office seeker is shooting him in the back with a bullet that says anti-reform efforts or something like that. It's one of those rare moments when the actual happening of history is so easy to read as a symbolic moment in what was going on politically in the country at the time. Goutot shot Garfield twice. The first bullet grazed his arm. The second entered his back and lodged by his stomach.
但他实际做的事情——因为感到被分赃体制欺骗而枪杀了一位总统——实在是太完美的象征了。这几乎就像加菲尔德的暗杀是一幅活生生的政治漫画，加菲尔德可以被贴上“改革派”的标签，他正走在华盛顿的火车站里。一个贴着“分赃体制”或“求职者”标签的人正用一颗写着“反改革努力”之类的子弹从背后射杀他。这是历史真实发生的情景如此容易被解读为当时国家政治局势象征性时刻的罕见时刻之一。吉托向加菲尔德开了两枪。第一颗子弹擦伤了他的手臂。第二颗子弹射入他的背部，卡在他的胃部附近。
And for nearly three months, there's hope that Garfield might survive. Doctors believe they can save him if they can just find the bullet. And the news is constantly coming out. Garfield's getting better. He ate breakfast today. Oh, no. Garfield's getting worse. He couldn't eat food today.
在将近三个月的时间里，人们一直期盼加菲尔德能够活下来。医生们相信，只要能找到子弹，他们就能救他。消息源源不断地传出。加菲尔德正在好转。他今天吃早饭了。哦，不。加菲尔德在恶化。他今天吃不下东西。
You know, oh, the doctors are looking at on him. They can't find the bullet. They keep sticking their fingers into his wound to try to get the bullet. Oh, they can't do it. Well, maybe, and the country is for months just in suspense and worried because they don't know whether the president is going to survive this or not. And in the meantime, the man that many Americans fear the most, the machine politician with 70 to 80 pairs of pants who once made more money than the president, that guy is now next in line to lead the country. He is freaking out that people are suspecting that he's involved in some way, that he is, part of this shadowy, you know, slimy side of politics. And there is a suspicion, oh, is Arthur
你知道的，哦，医生们正在给他检查。他们找不到子弹。他们不断把手指伸进他的伤口里试图取出子弹。哦，他们做不到。好吧，也许吧，几个月来，整个国家都处于悬念和担忧之中，因为他们不知道总统能否从这场灾难中幸存下来。与此同时，许多美国人最害怕的人——那个拥有 70 到 80 条裤子、曾经赚得比总统还多的政客——现在成了领导国家的下一个顺位人选。他惊慌失措，担心人们会怀疑他以某种方式参与其中，担心自己是这背后阴暗、你知道的、政治卑暗面的一部分。人们产生了怀疑：哦，难道亚瑟是幕后黑手吗？
behind this? And I think it potentially helps his case that rather than stepping in and saying, I will do it, that he essentially disappears. And people don't know where he is. He seems to be, he's just at home and he spends a lot of days crying, you know, and really being afraid of what's going to happen. And he finds himself in the situation where he means, he means. may be about to take on the largest job in the country and the most difficult job in the country, something he never has had an ambition to do. And the rest of the country, even the ones that don't think he was behind this, they are certain he will be a bad president. And you read about it that people were just going around saying, Chet Arthur is president. Chet Arthur
我认为，他没有介入并说“我来接管”，而是基本上隐身了，这可能对他的案情有所帮助。人们不知道他在哪里。他似乎只是待在家里的，很多天都在哭泣，你知道的，并且真的害怕将要发生的事情。他发现自己陷入了一种境遇：他可能即将接手全国最大、最困难的工作，这是一件他从未有过野心的事。而全国上下，甚至那些不认为他是幕后黑手的人，也确信他会成为一个糟糕的总统。你可以读到当时人们只是到处转悠着说：切特·亚瑟是总统？
as president? Like, can you imagine this? And I love the fact that his nickname was Chet, because there's something about having a president named Chet. Like, you imagine he's like, he's just like a real jock. He is surrounded by people saying, Arthur, you're bad at this. We're like, Arthur, we don't think you can do this. And Arthur, I think, is, he's so overwhelmed, sad and unhappy
切特·亚瑟当总统？这你能想象吗？我特别喜欢他的昵称叫切特，因为有一个名叫切特的总统总让人感觉怪怪的。就像你想象的那样，他就像个真正的运动健将。他周围都是这样的人在说：亚瑟，你这方面不行。或者像是在说：亚瑟，我们觉得你干不了这个。而亚瑟，我想，他是如此不知所措、悲伤、痛苦，
and emotionally suffering. While the country holds its breath, sending thoughts and prayers to President Garfield, someone new enters the chat. Julia Sand. Let's take a break to talk about our sponsor for today's episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude.
并在情感上備受折磨。正当全国上下屏住呼吸、为加菲尔德总统祈祷之际，一个新人物登场了：朱莉娅·桑。让我们休息一下，聊聊本期节目的赞助商 Anthropic，也就是 Claude 的幕后团队。
Have you ever wished you could hand off a task to someone while you're on the go. Claude is the collaborator that actually understands your entire workflow and things with you. Integrate Claude into any part of your project, keeping you focused on solutions. As your research assistant, Claude's research capabilities are comprehensive, reliable analysis with proper citations, turning hours of research into minutes. Claude becomes your command center by connecting to your professional tools like GitHub, Jira, HubSpot, Notion, and Google workspace.
你是否曾希望在路上时能把任务交给别人？Claude 是那个真正理解你整个工作流程并与你并肩思考的协作者。将 Claude 融入你项目的任何环节，让你专注于解决方案。作为你的研究助手，Claude 的研究能力全面、分析可靠且附有规范的引用，能将几小时的研究缩短至几分钟。通过连接 GitHub、Jira、HubSpot、Notion 和 Google workspace 等专业工具，Claude 成为了你的指挥中心。
Build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need. Delegate tasks big and small with co-work so you can handle other work while Claude runs. It even has checkpoints that lets you save progress and roll back to any previous state instantly. And when all the work is done, Claude can help you create a polished document, spreadsheet, or presentation directly in your file system. No need to worry about rough drafts that need heavy editing. For problems worth solving, get started with Claude. at clod.a.ai. That's clod.a.i.
通过描述你的需求来构建交互式工具和应用。通过协同工作（co-work）委派大小任务，这样你就可以处理其他工作，而 Claude 则在后台运行。它甚至具备检查点功能，让你能够即时保存进度并回滚到任何先前的状态。当所有工作完成后，Claude 可以直接在你的文件系统中帮你创建一份精美的文档、电子表格或演示文稿。无需担心需要大量修改的粗糙草稿。要解决值得攻克的问题，请访问 claw.a.i 开始使用 Claude。即 c-l-o-d 点 a 点 i。
This is the moment of this story where it stops being tragical and starts being magical in a way. It's because this is inspiring to me. So to recap, the country already has doubts about the spoil system. President Garfield's life hangs in the balance and his potential successor is hiding out in New York away from public view. when he receives the letter that starts to change his life. This is in August of 1881. Arthur receives this first letter from Julia Sand, and she is very much not the kind of person
故事的这个节点停止了悲剧色彩，在某种程度上变得神奇起来。因为这对我来说很具有启发性。简单回顾一下，全国上下对分赃体制已经产生了怀疑。加菲尔德总统生死未卜，他潜在的继任者正躲在纽约远离公众视线的地方，
who usually shows up in the historical record. Julia Sand is 31, unmarried, chronically ill, and confined to her home. She's a woman in an era when women have no political voice. She cannot vote. She has no platform or power or influence. She's invisible in every way that. matters in her time. But from that invisibility, she picks up a pen and writes to the vice president,
就在这时，他收到了这封开始改变他人生的信。那是 1881 年 8 月。亚瑟收到了来自朱莉娅·桑的第一封信，而她绝不是那种通常会出现在历史记录里的人。朱莉娅·桑 31 岁，未婚，长期患病，足不出户。在女性没有政治发声渠道的时代，她是一个女性。她没有投票权。她没有平台、权力和影响力。在对她那个时代重要的任何方面，她都是隐形的。但正是从这种隐形状态中，她拿起笔给副总统写了一封信，
a letter so politically astute, so beguiling, that it will transform him. And she comes in hot. August 27, 1881, to the Honorable Chester A. Arthur, the hours of Garfield's life are numbered. Before this meets your eye, you may be president. The people are bowed and in grief. But do you realize it? Not so much because he's dying as because you are his successor. And she talks about everyone is sure you will be a terrible president. But then she says, making a man president can change him. And she says, here's the thing you have to do. Reform. Rise to the emergency. Disappoint our fears. Force the nation to have faith in you. Show them from the first that you have none but the purest aims.
一封在政治上如此精明、如此迷人，以至于将改变他的信。她一上来就单刀直入。1881 年 8 月 27 日，致尊敬的切斯特·A·亚瑟阁下：加菲尔德的生命已所剩无几。在您看到这封信之前，您可能已经成为总统了。人们正黯然神伤。但您意识到了吗？这并非因为他濒临死亡，而是因为您将是他的继任者。她谈到每个人都确信你会是一个糟糕的总统。但接着她说：让一个人当总统可以改变他。她说，这是你必须要做的事情：改革。迎难而上。打破我们的担忧。迫使国家对你产生信心。从一开始就向他们展示你除了最纯粹的目标之外别无他求。
It may be difficult to inspire confidence, but persevere. In time, when you have given reason for it, the country will love and trust you. Sands' letter goes beyond just encouragement. It's a challenge. She picks one thing, one issue, and she makes it Arthur's mission. Civil Service Reform. If any man says with Arthur for president's civil service reform is doomed, prove that Arthur can be its finest champion.
要激发信心或许很难，但要坚持下去。假以时日，当你给出了理由，国家将会爱戴并信任你。桑的信不仅仅是鼓励。它是一个挑战。她挑选了一件事、一个议题，并将其变成了亚瑟的使命：公务员制度改革。如果有人说有亚瑟当总统，公务员制度改革就彻底无望了，那就证明亚瑟可以成为它最好的捍卫者。
She is a single-issue voter in this one. It is civil service reform. You can do it. Civil service reform. Civil service reform. And she makes it clear. This is how you prove you're not the man everyone thinks you are. I wish we knew more about why she decided to write this letter, why she had any faith in Arthur to begin with.
她在这个问题上是一个只关注单一议题的选民。这就是公务员制度改革。你能做到的。公务员制度改革。公务员制度改革。她明确指出：这就是你证明自己不是每个人所想的那种人的方式。我真希望我们能对她为什么决定写这封信、她为什么一开始对亚瑟有信心了解更多。
We just don't know. And all we can pick up are the clues from this letter and the 22 others that she writes after that, where she starts establishing herself as what she calls his dwarf saying that in the court, of kings, the dwarf was allowed to say the things that other people couldn't say, and to give the king his honest opinion. It's brilliant. She has no power, no influence, no formal standing. But she uses that powerlessness as a kind of power.
我们只是不得而知。我们所能捕捉到的，只有这封信以及她后来写的另外 22 封信中的线索，在那些信中，她开始确立自己作为她所谓的他的“侏儒”的身份，并说在国王的宫廷里，侏儒被允许说其他人不敢说的话，并向国王提供诚实的意见。这太绝了。她没有权力、没有影响力、没有正式地位。但她把这种无权无势变成了一种力量。
So she's writing to him saying, you have this decision for you. I think you should do it this way. Don't do it that way. Here's what I think you should do. But written also in a way that is frankly, like, really delightful, like very playful. She teases him often in one of the letters she talks about, she's like, oh, I saw it. Did you hear I saw a picture of that awful. President Arthur in the newspaper? He had devil horns, I think.
所以她写信给他：你面临这个决定，我认为你应该这么做。不要那样做。这是我认为你该做的。但这些信的语气坦白说也写得非常令人愉快、非常俏皮。她经常在信中取笑他，比如她在其中一封信里谈到，她会说：哦，我看到了。你听说了吗？我在报纸上看到了那个可怕的亚瑟总统的照片。我想他头上长了恶魔的角。
Like, she's very playful with him, but also very stern. And taking a tone with him that feels very presumptuous in that, again, she's writing to, at first, the man who is going to be president. And then to the president. In subsequent letters, Julia Sands' advice covers everything. By the way, do you take care of your health? Perhaps naturally it is good, but there are limits to human strength. She tells him to rest properly, to rise. horseback daily for circulation and health.
比如，她和他开玩笑时非常调皮，但同时也非常严厉。她对他采取的语气显得非常冒昧，因为再次强调，她一开始是写给即将成为总统的人。然后是写给总统。在随后的信件中，朱莉娅·桑的建议涵盖了方方面面。顺便问一句，你照顾好自己的健康了吗？也许你天生体质好，但人的体力是有限的。她告诉他要好好休息，每天骑马去促进血液循环和保持健康。
Nothing supplies the place of fresh air and sunshine. But she also tells him to stay away from New York and his old stalwart buddies, men like Roscoe Conklin, whose spoils machine made him rich. New York is the one spot on the continent where you positively ought not to be this fall. In coming to New York at this season, you do. You put yourself in temptation. And in a certain way, you put yourself in the power of unconstitutional. untrustworthy men. She pushes him to appoint qualified people, not political cronies, to stop the
没有什么能替代新鲜空气和阳光。但她也告诉他要远离纽约和他的老坚守派密友，比如罗斯科·康克林这样的人，正是他的分赃机器让他发了财。纽约是这个大陆上你今年秋天绝对不应该去的地方。在这个季节来到纽约，你是在自找诱惑。某种程度上，你把自己置于那些违宪且不值得信任的人的权力之下。她敦促他任命合格的人选，而不是政治亲信，停止
kickbacks or assessments to the party. Appoint those only of marked ability and of sterling character. Such may not be abundant, but you will find them if you seek them. To think about his legacy, about how history will judge him, about his children watching. Of all your friends, do you know which ones I like best to hear of being with you? your children, they are your guardian angels. Over and over, across the 23 letters, the message is the same. Do better, because you can be better. And Arthur actually listens.
向党组织输送利益或摊派。只任命那些能力显著、品格纯良的人。这样的人或许并不多，但只要你用心寻找，就一定能找到。去想想他的政治遗产，想想历史会如何评判他，想想他的孩子们正在看着他。在你所有的朋友中，你知道我最喜欢听哪一个陪伴在你的左右吗？是你的孩子们，他们就是你的守护天使。在这23封信中，核心信息一遍又一遍地重复着：做得更好，因为你有能力做得更好。亚瑟真的听进去了。
He doesn't just read her words. He acts on them. When he vetoes the River and Harbor Act of 1882, Julius Sand is genuinely delighted. Arthur says to Congress that it was filled with bogus local projects that were not in the national interest, writing it would set a bad precedent for the, quote, extravagant expenditure of public money. His veto was eventually overridden by Congress, but Julius Sand was genuinely satisfied with President Arthur's choice. She writes to congratulate him, saying she sees it as proof that he can do the right thing.
他不仅是在读她的信，更是付诸行动。当他在1882年否决《河流与港口法案》时，朱莉娅·桑是由衷地感到高兴。亚瑟对国会表示，该法案充斥着不符合国家利益的虚假地方项目，并写道，此举将为所谓的“公共资金的挥霍”开创一个糟糕的先例。尽管他的否决最终被国会推翻，但朱莉娅·桑对阿瑟总统的选择感到由衷的满意。她写信向他祝贺，称这证明了他能够做出正确的事情。
I want to complicate this, like, slightly in the fact that this didn't mean that Chester Arthur did all great fans in his presidency. I think he did really contemptible things as president, too. In Arthur's case, the worst of it was he did sign into law the Chinese Exclusion Act, which basically said Chinese people are not welcome in the United States for a certain period of time. In her letters, Julius and advised President Arthur to veto the Chinese Exclusion Act, because, as she put it, it is opposed to the spirit of America and to the spirit of civilization all around the world. It is mean and cowardly. More than that, it is a step back into barbarism.
我想稍微辩证地看待这一点，事实上，这并不意味着切斯特·亚瑟在他总统任内的所有举措都堪称伟大。我认为他在总统任上也做过一些确实令人不齿的事情。就亚瑟而言，其中最糟糕的一点就是他签署了《排华法案》，该法案基本上规定在一定时期内不欢迎中国人在美国居留。朱莉娅·桑在信中曾建议亚瑟总统否决《排华法案》，因为正如她所说，这违背了美国的精神，违背了全世界文明的精神。这是卑鄙而懦弱的。不仅如此，这是向野蛮主义的倒退。
At all events, do not let your administration be marked by any such disgraceful retrograde movements. Sand in her letters is saying, you've got to veto that bill. And he vetoes it the first time, but then it comes back to him, it's still a racist anti-immigration act, that singles out a specific ethnicity and nationality for not being allowed in the United States. And he realizes that they have the votes. to overcome his veto. And so he, I think, reluctantly signs it. And Julia Sand is frustrated with him about this. But despite spending his career benefiting from the spoil system, despite once being its patron saint, he begins to reform. In 1883, he signs the Pendleton Civil Service Reform Act. It's the first law that fundamentally changes how government works.
无论如何，绝不能让你的政府留下任何此类可耻的倒退行径。桑在信中说，你必须否决那个法案。他第一次确实将其否决了，但随后法案又回到了他的桌面上——这仍然是一项针对特定种族和国籍、禁止其进入美国的种族主义反移民法案。他意识到国会有足够的票数来推翻他的否决。因此，我认为他是不情愿地签署了它。朱莉娅·桑对此感到很沮丧。但尽管他的整个职业生涯都受益于分赃制，尽管他曾是这一制度的守护神，他还是开始推行改革。1883年，他签署了《彭德尔顿公务员制度改革法》。这是第一部从根本上改变政府运作方式的法律。
Certain federal jobs are now awarded based on merit, not political loyalty. The set group of jobs in the federal government, they're going to be awarded on the basis of merit, not on the basis of patronage, and they will not be turned over jobs. That you won't have this revolving door of a new government came in. We're going to kick everybody out. It's really the establishment of the permanent federal bureaucracy. You know, like allies don't just like take over. And because you donated a bunch of money, you become the tax collector or whatever. Like it is making those jobs permanent and consistent across. administration so that the job of government is permanent and consistent.
某些联邦职位现在开始根据能力而非政治忠诚度来授予。联邦政府中的特定职位，将根据能力而非裙带关系来分配，并且这些职位将不再随政权更迭而被撤换。你不会再看到新政府上台后，出现这种走马灯式的更迭。我们要把所有人赶出去。这实际上就是永久性联邦官僚机构的确立。你知道的，就好比盟友不会直接接管一切。不会因为你捐了一大笔钱，你就成了税务官之类的人。这就好比让这些职位在各届政府中保持永久性和连贯性，从而使政府的职能得以永久且稳定地运行。
Yes. And so you have, it's the very beginning of building up the institutional knowledge of how a government functions. The thing that is in such danger right now, because of the way that the current administration is handling, employing in the federal government, this is the beginning of that. And Arthur becomes a real champion for this act. Now civil servants are protected. They can't be fired just because a new president takes office. It's a complete reversal of the system Arthur built his career on. The guy they put on the ticket to appeal to champions of the spoil system has dismantled the system himself. The reformers have won the battle.
没错。所以这就成为了积累政府职能制度知识的最初起点。而鉴于现任政府在联邦政府雇佣问题上的处理方式，这种制度目前正处于极大的危险之中，这一切正是从那时开始的。亚瑟成为了这项法案的坚定捍卫者。现在，公务员得到了保护。他们不会仅仅因为新总统上台而被解雇。这是对亚瑟赖以起家的那个制度的彻底颠覆。那个被他们推上候选人宝座、用来迎合分赃制拥趸的人，竟然亲手拆解了这个制度。改革派赢得了这场战役。
I'm wondering if you know how his old cronies with the spoil system responded to his sort of about-face when he signed the Pendleton Act and championed it. He had a break with Conkling. I mean, Conkling also, he flamed out spectacularly at a certain point where he was mad about something. And he resigned his seat in the Senate. And he's like, you'll see, I'm so powerful, the legislature's going to send me right back. Because at that point, the legislature elected senators, people didn't direct elect senators. And the legislature was like, uh, thank you for giving us this opportunity to get rid of you. And so he flames out of government amazingly.
我想知道你是否了解，当亚瑟签署并大力推行《彭德尔顿法案》时，他在分赃制阵营中的那些老政客伙伴们作何反应。他与康克林决裂了。我是说，康克林在某个时候也因为对某些事感到不满而彻底崩溃了。他辞去了参议员职务。他当时的想法是：你们看好了，我是如此有权有势，立法机关马上就会把我重新选回去。因为在那个时候，参议员是由立法机关选举产生的，而不是由民众直接选举产生的。而立法机关的反应则是：呃，谢谢你给了我们这个摆脱你的好机会。于是，他在政坛上的政治生命以一种惊人的方式彻底黯然收场。
It's reported that Conkling then asks Arthur to make some typical spoil system appointments, but Arthur refuses. And when pressed on why he turned on his old mentor, Arthur says, quote, for the vice president, I was indebted to Mr. Conklin. But for the presidency of the United States, my debt is to the Almighty. That was it. The friendship was over. He cut ties with his spoil system buddies in New York,
据报道，康克林随后要求亚瑟进行一些典型的分赃制人事任命，但遭到亚瑟的拒绝。当被追问为什么要背叛自己的老导师时，亚瑟回答说：“关于副总统之位，我亏欠了康克林先生。但对于美利坚合众国的总统之位，我所亏欠的是全能的上帝。”事情就是这样。这段友谊结束了。他切断了与纽约分赃制死党们的联系，
just as Sand advised him to. I like to think of Chester Arthur's life that he has a devil on his shoulder and an angel on his shoulder, and Roscoe Conkling is the devil on his shoulder, and Julia Sand will become the angel on his shoulder. His actions as president do bear out not always the exact thing she wants him to do,
正如桑建议他的那样。我总喜欢把切斯特·亚瑟的人生想象成这样：他的肩膀一边坐着恶魔，另一边坐着天使，罗斯科·康克林就是他肩膀上的恶魔，而朱莉娅·桑则成了他肩膀上的天使。他作为总统的所作所为确实证明了——虽然并不总是完全按照她想要他做的那样去做，
but bears out the general direction she's trying to push him in. Why do you think Chester Arthur listens to her? I do imagine that he is touched by anyone having faith in him. When what he is hearing from outside and inside is, this is bad, you're the worst person that we could have in this position. And that anyone believes he's capable of it, I think is a big thing. But also that Arthur at this point, he's a widower, his wife has been dead for a number of years. And the way that these letters are written, you can't help but read them as there's this delightful young woman who believes in me
但确实朝着她试图推动他的大致方向在前进。你认为切斯特·亚瑟为什么会听取她的意见？我猜想，当有人对抱有信心时，他内心一定深受触动。当时他在外界和内部听到的全都是：这很糟糕，你是在这个职位上我们能选出的最糟糕的人。而居然有人相信他有能力胜任，我认为这意义重大。但同时也是因为，当时的亚瑟是个鳏夫，他的妻子已经去世好几年了。从这些信件的字里行间，你会不由自主地感受到：这里有一位迷人的年轻女性，她相信我，
and is speaking to me in a way that is intelligent and that is meaningful and when you're a man of a certain age who's interested in women to get a letter from a woman you've never met who is like, I believe in you, I think you can be great.
并且以一种既聪明又有意义的方式与我对话；当你是一个到了一定年纪、对女性感兴趣的男人时，能收到一封来自从未谋面的女子的信，信中说“我相信你，我认为你能成就伟大”，这种感觉……
Here's how to do it. It's written in this delightful way. I think it hit the bullseye of what he needed to hear at that moment and in a voice that he was eager to listen to or that was attractive to listen to. And I think if you read between the lines, you can kind of feel the possibility,
“该怎么做，请听我说。”信是以这种令人愉悦的方式写的。我认为它精准地击中了他在那个时刻最需要听到的心声，并且以一种他渴望倾听的、具有吸引力的声音表达了出来。我想如果你细细品味字里行间，你就能隐约感受到那种浪漫情愫的可能，
of something romantic. Maybe Sand hopes for it. Maybe Arthur wonders about it. And at some point, he actually goes and visits her. Could you talk about that, what happened there and what led to that? So we only know about this from a letter that Julia writes to Arthur that's dated August 24, 1882. And she talks in it about how, she says at the start, she goes, my friend. My friend.
或许桑对此抱有期许，或许亚瑟也对此浮想联翩。而在某个时刻，他真的去拜访了她。你能谈谈这件事吗？当时发生了什么，又是什么促成了这次会面？我们对这件事的了解，仅来源于朱莉娅写给亚瑟的一封信，信的日期是1882年8月24日。她在信中谈到了他是如何……她在开头说道：我的朋友。我的朋友。
How good you were to come and see me. How good you were to come and see me after all. And how badly you were repaid for it. And apparently from what we can pick up from the letter, he didn't announce. He didn't say, I'm stopping by. He just showed up. And at first, she didn't know who was there. She goes, wondering who that gentle-voiced Episcopal minister in the front parlor might be.
你来看望我是多么地好啊。你最终还是来看望了我，这是多么地好啊。而你却为此受到了多么不公正的回报。显然，从我们从信中能推断出的情况来看，他并没有提前通知。他没有说“我要顺道拜访”。他就这么直接出现了。起初，她甚至不知道是谁来了。她写道：当时还在纳闷，前厅里那个声音温和的圣公会牧师究竟会是谁呢。
And it turns out that it's present Arthur. And I've always imagined that this was Arthur on the spur moment. No, I'll do it. I'll go see her. And both of them having fantasies about what this moment would be like of finally meeting the other person. And again, Arthur has never written back to Julia. Until he shows up, other than his public actions, there's no way of knowing that he's even read the letters.
结果发现来者竟然是亚瑟总统。我一直想象这完全是亚瑟的一时兴起。“不，我要去。我要去见她。”他们两人或许都曾对这一刻充满幻想：最终能够与对方见面。而且再次强调，在此之前，亚瑟从未给朱莉娅回过信。直到他现身之前，除了他公开的政治行动外，没有任何迹象表明他甚至读过这些信。
So he literally just shows up out of nowhere. I'm afraid you had a, what shall I call it, a very stiff visit, which was a pity. For my family are not given to stiffness. But you see, you took them quite by surprise. The way that I read what happened is that her family will not leave the room. She says in the letter. She says, I thought if you did come, it would be to see me.
所以他 literalmente（字面意思）就这么毫无征兆地从天而降。我担心你经历了一次——我该怎么称呼它呢？——一次非常拘谨的会面，这实在太遗憾了。因为我的家人并不是那种拘谨的人。但你看，你把他们完全吓了一跳。我对当时情况的理解是，她的家人根本不肯离开房间。她在信中提到了这一点。她写道：我以为如果你真的来的话，是为了来看我的。
But now it is quite evident that it was my mother, sisters, brothers, and nephews in whom you were interested. And I think she's trying to say, like, you didn't spend enough time talking to me. But at the same time, it's, this is not a period when an unmarried man and an unmarried woman can go to a back room and talk easily by themselves. They have to sit in the front parlor. He says to her at some point, apparently, that she's been a little unjust to him in her criticism in the letters. And that's about as far as it goes. My brother said I was like the man in the Arabian nights who got the big jinny out of the vase
但现在很明显，你感兴趣的人其实是我的母亲、姐妹、兄弟和侄子们。我想她其实是想表达：你花在我身上的谈话时间根本不够。但与此同时，这也是一个未婚男女无法独自前往后室轻松交谈的时代。他们必须坐在前厅里。据透露，他在某个时刻对她说，她在信中的批评对他有些不太公允。事情也就差不多到此为止了。我哥哥说我就像《一千零一夜》里把大魔怪从瓶子里放出来，
and then was so frightened he wanted to put it back again. But that is not true. I did not want to put you back in your carriage and send you home again. There is part of me that believes that both Sand and Arthur had an inclination that maybe there was a romance to be had here,
然后又因为害怕得想把它塞回去的那个人。但事实并非如此。我并不是真的想把你塞回马车里再把你赶回家。我内心深处始终有这样一种信念：桑和亚瑟都曾隐隐感觉到，他们之间或许存在一段可能萌芽的浪漫，
which, spoiler alert, does not happen. You know, this is not that much of a magical fairy tale that the president gets letters from a pen pal and then marries her. In the romance novel version of this story that might happen. It seemed to me that you were not well, that you were very weary and worn out. I felt so sorry. I wanted to do something for you, and I didn't know what.
然而——剧透预警——这并没有发生。你知道，这并不是那种总统收到笔友来信随后便与之结婚的神奇童话。在这个故事的言情小说版本里，或许会有这种结局。在我看来，你当时身体不太好，显得非常疲惫和憔悴。我感到非常难过。我想为你做点什么，却又不知该从何下手。
Or rather, I did know, but is anything more unnatural than to be quite natural? If I had said, do lie down on the sofa. No one shall speak to you for an hour, and as soon as you are arrested, you must have some. dinner. You would have thought I was demented. Would you not? Julia's intuition was right. Chester was definitely not well. Within months, word would spread that he had a fatal kidney disease. He had maybe two years left, but Julia didn't know that. So Julia kept sending letters. Chester kept reading them, and he kept those letters for the rest of his life. And on his deathbed, when he instructed his
或者更准确地说，我其实知道，但还有什么比表现得自然更显得不自然的呢？如果我当时说：“快躺在沙发上吧。一小时内谁也不准跟你说话，等你一缓过劲来，必须马上吃点晚饭。”你肯定会觉得我疯了，不是吗？朱莉娅的直觉是准确的。切斯特的身体状况确实很糟糕。几个月内，他患有绝症肾病的消息便传开了。他可能只剩下两年的时间了，但朱莉娅并不知道这一点。于是，朱莉娅继续寄信。切斯特则继续阅读，并将这些信件珍藏了余生。在临终前，当他嘱咐自己的
son to burn all evidence of his life's work. He spared those 23 letters. We do know that the letters still meant something to him. They must have because he doesn't throw them away. He doesn't have them burned. He keeps them. And you could say that his change in behavior when it came to things like civil service reform was shifting with political wins or something like that. But it doesn't seem like it. It seems like he really is really paying attention to those. letters. And when he can, following the guidance, she's giving him. And he doesn't just hold on to the ones from before that meeting. He holds on to all of them. They must have meant something. We'll never really know for sure exactly. And all we have to go from is, is their existence and that Arthur did
儿子烧毁他一生心血的所有证据时，他却唯独留下了那23封信。我们确实知道，这些信件对他而言意义非凡。它们一定意义重大，因为他没有把它们扔掉，也没有让人烧毁它们，而是将它们保存了下来。你可以说，他在公务员改革等问题上的态度转变只是顺应了政治风向之类的事情。但事实似乎并非如此。看起来他确实在认真对待这些信件，并且在力所能及的范围内，遵循着她给他的指引。而且他不仅保留了那次会面之前的信件，而是将所有的信件都留存了下来。这些信件一定有着特殊的意义。我们永远无法百分之百确切地知道原因，我们所能依据的，仅仅是它们的存在，以及亚瑟确实发生了
change, that he did change his president and became someone who stood for reform rather than standing for the spoil system. Yeah. The letters are amazing to read. and they feel very persuasive and they feel very motivating to me. But why do you think they hit Chester Arthur the way they do? Why do you think they make him change? Arthur comes from, at least in his upbringing, from a moral background. Arthur's father is this abolitionist minister, very anti-slavery, like gets in trouble for the devotion he has to the anti-slavery cause. And you have to assume that at least some of that is buried in Arthur kind of waiting to reemer.
改变——他确实转变了总统的立场，成为了一位代表改革而非代表分赃制的政治人物。是的。这些信件读起来令人惊叹，它们极具说服力，对我而言也充满了激励作用。但你认为为什么它们会对切斯特·亚瑟产生如此大的触动？你觉得是什么促使他发生了改变？亚瑟的成长背景中，至少在道德底色上是有所承载的。亚瑟的父亲是一位废奴主义牧师，立场极度反奴隶制，甚至因为对废奴事业的极端投入而惹上过麻烦。你不得不假设，至少有一部分这样的基因深埋在亚瑟内心深处，等待着再次唤醒。
And I wonder if after years of living in a system where that that moral center was not rewarded or cultivated or wanted or asked for, that her letters reconnect him with that part of himself, where it goes, oh, no, no, there is, this is more the the world I was raised in, you know, or this was this was the understanding of how a person is supposed to be and what they're supposed to stand for that my father tried to put into me when I was young about like, you've got to do the right thing and stand up for justice. That rediscovery of his moral center doesn't stay personal. It becomes systemic. Arthur helps create a government run on merit, not connections. And suddenly, that government is capable of accomplishing things on a massive scale, the things that make a nation great. I mean, it really does set up a competent government that can meaningfully fight two war wars. It sets up why the 20th century is the American century, in my opinion. I think you're exactly right. The things that America accomplished in the 20th century are of such a massive scale, winning the Second World World, like all the New Deal programs, the Social Security Administration, being able to pass the Civil Rights Act and the Voting Rights Act and then enforce them. These are things that can only be handled by a government that has a baseline of competency and basic productivity. Landing on the moon. Like there's no way that's happening if you don't have a government that is set up to do all the little things that you need to do. Just the fact that When the Apollo astronauts lifted off into space, you knew that even though this was private companies hired to build this equipment, that they had gone through a vetting process that ensured that it was not being done just through kickbacks.
我在想，在经历多年生活在一个不奖赏、不培育、不需要也不渴求这种道德核心的体制中之后，她的信件重新唤醒了他内心的这一部分，让他觉得：哦，不，不，这才是……这更像是我成长的那种世界，你知道的，或者说，这才是父亲在我年轻时试图灌输给我的关于“一个人应该怎样生活、应该坚守什么信念”的理解——关于你必须做正确的事、为正义挺身而出。这种道德核心的重新发现并没有停留在个人层面，而是上升为了系统性的变革。亚瑟帮助建立了一个靠能力而非关系运转的政府。突然之间，这个政府有能力在宏观规模上成就伟业——那些让一个国家变得伟大的事情。我是说，这确实建立起了一个能打两场战争的称职政府。依我之见，正是这一切奠定了20th（二十）世纪何以成为“美国世纪”。我想你完全说对了。美国在20th（二十）世纪取得的成就是如此宏大，比如赢得第二次世界大战，所有的“新政”计划、社会保障署，能够通过《民权法案》和《投票权法案》并将其付诸执行。这些都是只有在一个具备基准竞争力和基本行政效能的政府管理下才能处理的事情。登月。如果你没有一个能够胜任所有日常基础事务的政府架构，这些根本是不可能发生的。单单是这样一个事实：当阿波罗号宇航员发射升空进入太空时，你心里很清楚，尽管这些设备是雇佣私营公司制造的，但它们都经过了一套严格的审查程序，从而确保其中没有涉及任何利益输送。
And it wasn't just that a congressman's nephew suddenly opened an aerospace company. Like, you can't accomplish any of these things without having a basic faith that the government can do its job professionally. And that all starts to. And have some consistency across administrations of like the, you know, The Apollo program, for example, it starts under Kennedy, and they land on the moon under Nixon. That Nixon could found the EPA, and then for the next 50 years, no matter who is president, it could do its job of keeping water and air relatively clean. And there's a constancy to the government. And it feels like America can last because it has people working for it who their highest loyalty is not for the Democratic Party of the Republican Party. It means that the government belongs to the American people in a very real way that it doesn't when it belongs to whichever party happens to be in power at that time.
而且这不仅仅是某个国会议员的侄子突然开了一家航空航天公司。如果没有一种基本的信任——即相信政府能够专业地履行其职责——你就不可能完成其中任何一项伟业。而这一切都始于……并且在各届政府之间保持了一定的连贯性，比如，阿波罗计划始于肯尼迪任内，他们却在尼克松任内登上了月球。尼克松可以创立国家环境保护局（EPA），在此后的50年里，无论谁当总统，它都能履行好保持水质和空气相对清洁的职责。政府展现出了一种稳定性。这让人觉得美国能够长久存续，是因为它拥有一批将最高忠诚度奉献给国家而非民主党或共和党的工作人员。这意味着政府在非常真实的意义上属于美国人民，而不再归属于某一个恰巧在那个时期当权的政党。
And you can't really overstate how much we as a nation and as individual citizens have benefited from this professional impartial, nonpartisan bureaucratic service. As much as it's easy to complain about it, it doesn't move fast enough. Oh, like these people, you know, they care more about their little fiefdoms than they do about helping this. thing or doing this other thing, it's still so much better than the alternative, which is living in a chaos world. We complain about the bureaucracy. We vilify it as slow and inefficient. But a consistent and competent bureaucracy is what made this country capable of the achievements
我们作为一个国家以及作为个体公民，从这种专业、公正、非党派的官僚服务中获益究竟有多深，无论怎样高估都不为过。尽管人们很容易抱怨它行动不够迅速，或者觉得“这些人（你知道的），他们更关心自己的一亩三分地，而不是去帮助解决某个问题或做点别的什么”，但它仍然比另一种选择——生活在一个混乱的世界里——要好得多。我们抱怨官僚体制，将其贬低为迟钝和低效。但正是这种持续且称职的官僚体制，才让这个国家有能力创造20th（二十）世纪的种种成就。
of the 20th century. And we owe that, at least in part, to Julia Sand, just a regular American who positioned herself as the voice of the president's conscience. She changed the course of American history, and we've lived off the fruits of her audaciousness, off her belief that a president could be better. And she is buried today in Brooklyn at Greenwood Cemetery, and she's just in the family plot.
我们至少在某种程度上要感谢朱莉娅·桑，一个普通的美国人，她将自己定位为总统良知的代言人。她改变了美国历史的进程，而我们至今仍享受着她的大胆果敢所结出的硕果——源于她坚信总统可以变得更好。她如今安葬在布鲁克林的绿木公墓（Green-Wood Cemetery），就躺在家族墓地里。
She does not have a headstone of her own. Years ago, I visited her grave and was just, I was so moved by seeing just that you could just walk by and not know that she was there. And that's the life she led was she was a woman who, if you didn't know her personally, just walked by her house, you didn't know she was there. And it's only because of this kind of amazing story, this amazing connection through these letters. These letters are the only thing of her that survives that we really know of today. And it's this amazing thing to me where it feels like Julius Sand kind of saves Arthur in a way by helping to motivate him to become the better president that he could. be so that when he leaves office, people go, actually, you know what, he was pretty good.
她没有属于自己的独立墓碑。多年前我曾去拜访过她的墓地，当时深受触动，仅仅是因为你走过那里时，可能根本不会意识到她就长眠于此。这正是她过往人生的写照：她是一个如果你不曾私下认识她、只是从她门前走过，便根本不会察觉她存在的人。而正因为这个宛如神迹般的故事、通过这些信件建立的奇妙联系，这些信件成为了她留存于世的唯一遗物，才让我们今天真正知晓了她。在我看来，这实在是一段奇妙的经历：朱莉娅·桑在某种程度上通过激励亚瑟成为一名更优秀的总统，从而拯救了亚瑟，使得他在卸任时，人们会评价说：“事实上，你知道吗，他其实相当不错。”
I thought he was going to be terrible, but he wasn't that bad. You know, he was okay. And in a very real sense, Arthur saves Julia from being forgotten by history by holding onto those letters. And because those letters exist, we still know her name and we know that she existed in this world. There's so many things in the story that becomes symbols of things. And she becomes a symbol to me for all those people who have one opportunity. maybe to make their voice heard and they make their voice heard and it nudges history in a different direction. You know, she's one of these many, many people who in our country where we have this understanding of like, well, the ordinary American is the backbone of our system and our country and
“我本来以为他会是个糟糕透顶的总统，但他其实没那么差。你知道的，他挺合格的。”而在一个非常真实的意义上，亚瑟通过妥善保存这些信件，拯救了朱莉娅，使其免于被历史彻底遗忘。正因为这些信件的存在，我们今天才依然知晓她的名字，知道她曾在这个世界上存在过。这个故事中有太多的细节最终都成了某种象征。在我看来，她成为了所有那些普通人的象征——他们或许只有一次机会让自己的声音被听见，而当他们发声时，便推动了历史朝着不同的方向发展。你知道的，在我们这个国家，我们普遍认为“普通美国人是我们体制、国家以及一切重要事物的顶梁柱”，而她正是这千千万万普通人中的一员。
everything that's important. Like, you can reach out to the president of the United States and it'll make your name, if not legendary, then at least a little bit immortal in a way that it wouldn't be otherwise. Julia Sann's final letter to Chester Arthur was sent on September 15th. 1883 My very bad friend Who does not deserve that I should care where he goes Or what becomes of him
你可以向美利坚合众国的总统发出心声，即便无法让你的名字流芳百世，也至少能让它以某种别的方式获得些许不朽。朱莉娅·桑写给切斯特·亚瑟的最后一封信寄于1883年9月15日。我那极其糟糕的朋友，不配让我去关心他去哪里，或者他会有什么结局。
Are you coming to Newport? One day I hear that you are The next that you are not At present I'm staying at Mrs. Ives A quiet little house in a quiet little street And we so seldom are near Do come if you can Yours sincerely
你要来纽波特吗？我今天听说你要来，明天又听说你不来了。目前我住在艾夫斯夫人的那栋小房子里，位于一条安静的小街上，我们极少有机会聚在一起。如果可以的话，请务必来吧。真诚的，
G-I-S. Elliot Kalin, it's always fun to talk with you. Thank you so much for doing this. Thank you, Roman. This has been such a pleasure. Anytime you want me to come and talk about Chesteray-Arthur, I'll do it. I'll be there. Elliot Kalin is an Emmy P-Body and Writers Guild award-winning comedian and writer.
G-I-S。埃利奥特·卡林（Elliot Kalin），与你交谈总是充满乐趣。非常感谢你做客节目。谢谢你，罗曼。这是一段非常愉快的时光。任何时候只要你想让我来聊聊切斯特·A·亚瑟，我随叫随到，我一定奉陪。埃利奥特·卡林是一位荣获艾美奖、皮博迪奖以及美国编剧工会奖的喜剧演员兼编剧。
A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. This episode was produced by Priscilla Al-Ala. B, who also voiced the letters of Julia Sand. Our other producers are Ellie Lightfoot and Brennan Dahldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Mixing by Iver Manly.
《美国100件历史物件》是99% Invisible与BBC Studios联合制作的节目。本节目由我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）主持并策划。本集由普莉希拉·阿拉拉·B（Priscilla Al-Ala. B）制作，她同时也是朱莉娅·桑信件的配音演员。我们的其他制作人是埃利·莱特福特（Ellie Lightfoot）和布伦南·达尔多夫（Brennan Dahldorf）。助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔（Isaac Fisher）。本系列由安妮·布朗（Annie Brown）和考特尼·哈雷尔（Courtney Harrell）剪辑。混音由艾弗·曼利（Iver Manly）完成。
Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2. From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London.
事实核查由埃米·布拉肯（Amy Bracken）负责。主题曲创作者是斯旺·雷尔（Swan Real）。99% Invisible的执行制作人是凯茜·图（Kathy Tu）。BBC Studios的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。制作协调员是香恩·帕莱（Shan Palais），制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特（Mabel Finnegan Wright）。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）绘制。99% Invisible是SiriusXM播客大家庭的成员之一，总部位于美丽的上城奥克兰，加利福尼亚州。BBC Studios总部位于美丽的西伦敦白城。
If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. Thank you again to the sponsor of today's episode, Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Claude is the collaborator making your day-to-day life easier. Set up workflows with co-work to run on a schedule like daily reports and weekly summaries. Claude can scan your Slack and email to build you a prioritized action list. That's how I use it for this project, actually. It takes all the suggestion emails and puts them in the spreadsheet for me so I can check them all out and share them. You can build interactive tools and apps by describing what you need.
如果您想与我们取得联系，或者有物件希望我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至 100Objects@99PI.org。再次感谢今天节目的赞助商 Anthropic，即 Claude 背后的团队。Claude 是让您的日常生活变得更加轻松的得力助手。通过 co-work 设置日常报告和每周总结等按计划运行的工作流。Claude 可以扫描您的 Slack 和电子邮件，为您生成一个按优先级排序的行动清单。事实上，这就是我为这个项目使用它的方式。它把所有的建议邮件都帮我整理进电子表格里，这样我就可以一一查看并进行分享。您只需描述您的需求，就能构建交互式工具和应用。
Like custom calculators, data visualization dashboards, even prototypes, all without writing a single line of code. For problems worth solving, get started with Claude at clod.aI. That's clawed.aI. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如自定义计算器、数据可视化仪表板，甚至是原型，全程无需编写一行代码。对于值得解决的问题，请访问 clod.ai 开始使用 Claude。网址是 clawed.ai。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。